we're the pittsburgh steelers we know
everyone's come coming for us
um if you didn't know who
i'm not trying to take any shots at
anybody but if you didn't know who
america's team was you should have seen
the stands and all the terrible tiles
um dallas may be
america's team but we'll be the world's
team because we got fans everywhere
they're the best in the world
that's a shot right there that's a shot
right there and you know as a man who
grew up in cincinnati you know ben
roethlisberger has ripped my heart out
and stomped on it probably more than 10
or 15 times probably more than 25 times
now that i stopped thinking about it and
actually say it out loud
but they really probably are the world's
team because no matter where you go
there is always terrible towels there is
always steeler fans and it runs deep to
their core when they rule on their
pittsburgh steelers
brother let me tell you this i've been
around the world and people have
recognized me from playing with the
patriots but you ever hang out with
heinz ward
man they know this dude and all the
pittsburgh still is everywhere
it's just a very popular team and big
ben i mean he's tremendous and he's been
so impressive think about a guy coming
off a major injury doing all the rehab
that he's he had to do and playing on a
level that he played he got hurt and
that's the thing that i'm afraid of for
big ben i mean he looks terrific um even
when he went out and he you know he was
having some problems they came in mason
rudolph came in didn't look great big
ben came back in and did his thing in
the fourth quarter but
they're gonna have to keep him healthy
if he doesn't stay healthy they're gonna
have problems they're gonna have
problems jack i i don't know what they
do if big ben
if he doesn't stay healthy
well i hear you on that and rodney
report came out this week that he hurt
both knees in the game but in true big
bend fashion still expected to play i
mean it's it's unbelievable with this
guy i swear the football season doesn't
start and sometimes it almost feels like
a game doesn't start when you watch the
pittsburgh steelers until big ben gets
dinged up goes the locker room gets a
shot of something comes back onto the
field back into the game and plays
better and plays better like the game
does not start until that happens he
loves and lives for that moment where he
takes a shot and all of a sudden the
engines fire up
jack let me ask you this man because
i've watched this for years
it's been just kind of
i'm not saying he's ever faking it but
is he over dramatizing his injuries at
time i just need to know from your
perspective because i see it all the
time i've watched him since i retired i
played against ben when he was a rookie
i picked him off took him 87 yards to
the house but to me you see ben ah and
then all of a sudden he comes in he
leads his team to victory and he's the
hero
let me think like a respectful way to
say this there is not a single doubt in
any part of my brain that exactly what
you just said is true one million
percent he's been doing it forever ring
the bell ding ding ding you are dead on
rodney he loves it he lives for it he
wants you to know he's feeling just a
little bit of something he likes to he
here's what big ben likes to do he likes
to write next the next day the monday
headlines on sunday he's like you know
he might as well just phone up to the
press box and tell him here's the story
boys i'm coming back and winning it but
in case you're in case you forgot i got
a little bit of a sore knee now watch
every game every week that's what he
does and you know it's funny too because
i was watching some shows early and
everybody's talking about um well
the lack of explosive plays and and this
offense is different what people don't
understand is ben has he had a surgery
he had a major surgery so they're not
trying to let him just hold the ball
they get real he's getting rid of ball
quicker and they use the quick passes to
set up the shots down the field
so to me you're not going to always be
able to come out and have explosive
plays you have to win the way you have
to win and sometimes that calls for
running the football sometimes it's
quick quick passes sometimes it shots
down the field
this is an offense that is just
similarly to the kansas city chiefs they
are just so wealthy with playmakers i
mean it is just everywhere you look
even eric ebron i mean deontay johnson
chase claypool juju smith schuster
washington made a big play yesterday
it overwhelms you benny schnell uh you
know connor coming out of the backfield
he's having a big year it just
overwhelms you with things you have to
defend and they make you forget about
ebron and then he's wide open big ben
finds him uh and i don't think i've seen
big ben play this well in a long time
either but when you can't figure out who
the number one wide receiver is and
watching the way that teams are
defending them now it seems like they're
locking in on chase claypool and saying
claypool's the one we're gonna take away
and now juju is just having huge games
because that is when he does his best
work when he doesn't get all that
attention he can go over across the
middle of the field and just crush these
defenses so what he did when they had
antonio brown it's what he's doing again
when they have uh chase claypool taking
all the heat off him
brother you just took the words right
out of my mouth because he wasn't really
used to that when a b was there because
a b drew all the attention so he was
able to shine in the slot now people
give him attention but clay
claypool he's been terrific i mean think
how big and how physical he had some
opportunities down the field where he
kind of misguided the ball um but yeah i
mean they have weapons all over the
place and the frustrating part about it
from a defensive standpoint is you don't
know
who to take away do you take away
claypool do you take away deonte johnson
washington juju you don't know who to
take away and then we haven't even
talked about when you mentioned double e
eric ebron
he's a fantastic young tight end and
which can help him james connor he runs
he's been running the ball extremely
hard his defense
i look at ben and ben's doing a terrific
job leading his team but also when i
watch him he looks like he's 90 years
old when he's trying to run the football
so
he needs to stop trying to run because
he looks like an old man running
yeah he might not be 90 but he's at
least pushing 80. i can guarantee you
that i mean the way he takes off and
runs but but the thing about big ben is
that you still have to think about it
like no matter how old he looks he still
runs for that one or two first downs a
game that just breaks your back as a
defense he's always done it no matter
how old he is or how injured you know
it's even back to your earlier point you
know he's got the sore knee and you're
going
thank goodness big ben's not going to
run for that third down in this game and
then he still does every single week
doesn't even matter how sore that knee
is he'll get that first down and then
he'll get up and limp back to the huddle
it's the worst part about playing
against him
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports